في اطول معاركها منذ بدء حربها على
اوكرانيا تحاول القوات الروسيه منذ نحو
سبعه اشهر السيطره على مدينه باخمه
الاستراتيجيه شماليه مقاطعه دونيتسك وسط
مقاومه ضاريه من القوات الاوكرانيه
للحيلوله دون سقوط مدينه تعدها خط الدفاع
الاخير عن باقي المناطق التي لا تزال تحت
سيطرتها هناك لا سيما مدينه كراماتورسك
التحول الاهم في مسار القتال بمحيط باخ
موت في الاسابيع الاخيره جاء بعد ان رمت
ميليشيا فاجنر المجموعه العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه بكامل ثقلها في اتون المعركه وتصدر
مقاتلها خطوط القتال الاماميه مع التركيز
على قطع كافه خطوط الامداد عن القوات
الاوكرانيه
المتحصنه وسطباخموت بالتزامن مع قصف لا
يهدؤ على مواقعها
يؤكد رئيس مجموعه فاغناريه في جيني بروجين
ان باخموت اصبحت محاصره بشكل شبهي كامل
وان هناك طريقا واحدا فقط بقي مفتوحا امام
القوات الاوكرانيه لكي تخرج من المدينه
بريكوجين دعا الرئيس الاوكراني الى سحب
قواته من هناك في اقرب وقت ممكن
اتوجه الى الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
المحترم وحدات فاجنر العسكريه اصبحت تحاصر
بخمت بشكل شبه كامل ولم يبقى لهم سوى طريق
واحد والطوق يشتد حول المدينه
على الجانب الاوكراني بدات الرسائل
متضاربه ففي الوقت الذي اعلن فيه قائد
اللواء الميكانيكي الثامن والعشرين بالجيش
الاوكراني يوري ماديار ان وحدته
الاستطلاعيات تلقت امرا بالانسحاب من
باخموت اكدت القوات البريه في الجيش
الاوكراني ان قائدها زار المدينه واستمع
الى تقارير القاده الميدانيين بشان مسار
القتال هناك كما اطلع على القضايا
الاشكاليه المتعلقه بزياده القدره
الدفاعيه للوحدات في الخطوط الاماميه
وسواء انعكست هذه التطورات خلافا داخل
المعسكر الاوكراني اما انها مجرد تكتيكات
ميدانيه فان اخر المعلومات القادمه من
باخموت تفيد بان قتالا شرسا لا يزال يدور
على المحور الشمالي للمدينه حيث يقع ما
يمكن وصفه بالشريان الاخير للقوات
الاوكرانيه القادر على ضخ تعزيزات عسكريه
لها تحول دون سقوط المدينه بيد المقاتلين
الروس